à la réunion le département est l'un des
acteurs qui oeuvrent à développer ses
relations et ses échanges avec les pays
de la zone
et les meilleures illustrations de ces
échanges se sont ces visages ces
réunionnais volontaires qui partent en
mission à l'étranger
assistant d'enseignement en langues
française animateurs ou chargé de
mission dans une ambassade en appui à la
francophonie
ces réunionnais se construisent dans
cette india océanie et font rayonner la
francophonie sur ces territoires
[Musique]
grâce à la coopération valériane huarui
nelson à 20 sont en mission à l'alliance
française en afrique du sud
chaque année le département propose près
d'une centaine de ces huits dans toute
la zone océan indien
j'aurais été reconnaissante d'avoir pu y
participer et je retiendrai toutes les
rencontres que j'aurais faty sié qui
m'ont fait grandir
que ça soit humainement
professionnellement j'ai vraiment là
l'occasion de respirer de tout penser
autrement
ces ambassadeurs de la réunion et de la
francophonie se sont forgées de
nouvelles expériences qui leur offriront
à l'avenir des opportunités d'insertion
professionnelle
[Musique]
après un séjour de deux ans en tanzanie
en tant que chargé de mission à
l'ambassade française karine corps et
rentrer à la réunion
forte de cette mobilité de ses
enseignements karine est aujourd'hui
formatrice au centre international
d'études pédagogiques
la pinte de professionnels une
expérience extrêmement riche et puis
d'un point de vue humain à
l'expatriation je pense que se trouve
aux russes on se remet beaucoup en
question canton
confronté aux cantons les impliquer dans
la culture des autres on remet en
question sa propre clé de sa propre
culture certains aspects sa propre
lecture ça permet de prendre du recul
le sens riches de s'enrichir des
richesses des autres
[Musique]
me rozoy roux et michel félicité ont
toutes les deux temps telle aventure du
contrat unique d'insertion seychelles
pendant deux ans me rosoirs ou a
travaillé comme journaliste à la
télévision seychelloise à son retour à
la réunion
elle profite de cette expérience pour
créer sa société de production et
réalise aujourd'hui un documentaire pour
une chaîne nationale c'est que vraiment
c'est une opportunité positive parce que
je me suis remise en question sur le
plan humain sur le plan social sur le
plan culturel sur le plan relationnel
économique sur tous les plans et j'ai
appris à composer à travailler à
découvrir la mentalité seychelloise
michel félicité était rédactrice pour un
journal seychellois une opportunité pour
cette jeune femme qui a découvert la
coopération avec le département nous
donne en ou distribuera des fiches en
fait de mission dans plusieurs
destinations y aller c'est shia
madagascar il ya l'inde dont il ya
différents dispositifs dans toute la
zone
et moi je sais pas pourquoi déjà c'était
les seychelles et après j'ai récupéré
toutes les fiches des seychelles et j'ai
regardé dans le lot et là il y en avait
1 c'était pour être consultant et
journaliste au quotidien seychelles
nation j'ai fait c'est le truc de ma vie
c'est un vieux rappelle au collège avait
commencé à faire le journal ensuite au
lycée jean hinglo avec stéphanie on
était dans la radio hinglo le
journalisme il ya quelque chose qui
m'appelle là dedans c'est un vieux rêve
que je vais pouvoir enfin réaliser 37
ans et ben il faut y aller qu'on a un
vrai faut y croire quand je vois tous
ces articles là je me dis quelle chance
d'avoir pu écrire tous les jours en
français en créole et en anglais cette
coopération en tout cas
mahoux vers encore plus grand les yeux
plus grands le coeur et a continué à
avancer dans tout ce que j'ai à faire
voilà le but aujourd'hui c'est de
permettre à ceux qui sont jeunes et
moins jeunes de pouvoir avoir quand il
ya parfois pas la possibilité d'un
emploi sur place de pouvoir justement
ouvrir de nouvelles expériences
comprendre l'océan indien et dans le
cadre du marché futures la mobilité ou
c'est-à-dire va être une des mobilités
les plus intéressantes pour que
justement il est la possibilité d'une
expérience et la possibilité aussi de se
dire je peux aussi travaillé dans ces
pays très proche de chez nous mais
parfois très éloignés dans ce qu'on
pensait faire de notre vie
[Musique]